alright here's another question from
Cameron us he wants to know how long if
at all before a man mission to Titan
would this be a public or private sector
venture yeah that's a longer way out
there Titans as a long hallway how long
would it take to get to Titan well join
your rocket ship took five years right
that's a long time five years and this
is we don't have the technology right
now to stay away from all that radiation
it's not clear how bad that is how much
radiation enough to kill you which is
you probably don't want even to kill a
baby that maybe could adapt more and so
on when you try to make it better but
babies that's not how a diaper thing
down a whole bunch of babies which one
made it through it have no trouble
wearing diapers yeah they're send like a
twelve-year-old a bunch of 12 year olds
that will grow up slowly during the
mission but what we were genius you need
to be you need to be talking to that
congressman the elevator Mass how much
trouble did you have with bone loss
calcium loss I only been in my trips for
two weeks at a time though so it wasn't
you but we've got that licked we think
but we've got it licked through lots of
exercise how much do you lose you can
lose a very significant amount if you
did nothing yeah in space if you did not
exercise you could you would lose a lot
how much do you have sir sighs when you
go so in sprite now to counteract that
there is some medicine you can take and
that's again a benefit of the space
program because it also applies to
osteoporosis to prevent bone loss but
still the way we've gotten around that
we don't have bone loss it's not an
issue anymore but what we have to do to
counteract it there's two hours of
exercise six days a week
oh wow so that's that's significant it's
a lot of times where you're on the
payroll your size in space there's
machines with resistance yes so there's
a good point because you can lift
weights all you want make them doing any
good in space resistant that's crazy
you're like hercules bill yeah but it's
ours to crush that's sometimes the way
it's described when it's
the fritz be careful of the thing but it
works on Springs and Thera bands like
you might have seen in rehab medicine so
it's resistive exercise plus it's also a
treadmill is generally a popular way to
exercise so it's both cardio and it's
also resistive exercise and it's a
resistive exercise that keeps your bones
in good shape to this question yes it's
it's a long way and who's paying for
it's a lot of fuel